>>
Tom Manshreck: Welcome, developers. Ah, my
name is Tom
Manshreck. I am a technical writer. I write
the Maps API
documentation. Probably you get a lot of engineers
giving
talks. I'm a writer. Um, so I'm -- I'm here
to kind of
give you, ah, a different perspective. This
is more of a
tutorial for one of our products, which is
the Maps Data
API. And you probably are pretty familiar
with this right
now, but, ah, we have a live blog in wave.
So you can use
this bit.ly to get on the, ah, live wave and,
ah, pose
questions and ask them. I'll leave this up
for a little
bit. Um, just a little bit about myself. I've
been at the
Maps API team since 2007. I think you've seen
a lot of good
stuff today. We've launched the Place API,
or we will
launch it soon. Um, and we've also, ah, basically
migrated
the V3 to be the default application. So,
on today, I'm
going to talk about the Maps Data API. Um,
first of all,
how many people are familiar with V3? [ pause
while
audience responds ] And how many people are
using V2
applications? [ pause while audience responds
] All right,
so it's roughly half and half. Um, so what
I'm going to be
doing today is -- is basically describing
how you can use
the Maps Data API to do a matchup in V3. Um,
now what
counts as Maps Data? I -- I like to look at
Maps Data in
terms of three basic categories of stuff.
Um, you can have
your own personal data. Um, this is the kind
of stuff
you're walking around and, you know, you have
a favorite
coffee shop. You want to get -- you want to
take it down.
Do it by location. Um, another one would be
a shared model.
Um, and a shared model would be like you have
a group of
friends. You -- you have a bunch of bike paths
you want to
-- want to share at -- in a club, or something
like that.
Um, and then, finally, there's the public
model. Um, many
of you in business are going to like that,
because the
public model allows you to give your data
to your consumers.
Um, so basically the Maps Data API allows
you to pretty
quickly get an application running that presents
your data
to your users. So why store in the Cloud?
Um, I think
probably many of you probably use Gmail. Um,
I've learned a
lot of Gmail. Um, this is, um, ah, a model
for storing
geospatial data in the Cloud, um, in the Google
Cloud. Um,
it is safer. You know, we have redundancy.
Um, it's
exposed via multiple interfaces. Um, what
I'll -- what I'll
show you today is a -- is a Maps Data API
that you
manipulate, but anything that you put there
will actually
show up on Maps.Google.com in your My Maps
directory, once
you're logged in. Um, and, finally, it's
-- it's accessible
from any browser or application or server,
meaning that you
can provide one application to serve data
to people looking
on a desktop or a mobile device or to, ah,
another service.
And we do use the, ah, this uses, ah, Google
Data platform,
so we do use the open standards of Atom. So
what's the Maps
Data API? Um, it's an interface to Maps Data
stored in
Google Cloud. And it's -- it's basically a
REST API. Um,
which is a cool data API, which allows you
to do basic
create, read, update, and deletes. Um, it
does these
through HTTP requests. So you can think of
these things as
URLs or actually kind of functions with parameters.
Um,
and, in a kind of neat way, create would be
a POST. So if
you send a POST to a URL, what that says is
I want to create
something. If you send a GET, oh, I want to
read something.
If you send a PUT, it means I want to update
something. And
you can also send a DELETE to delete something.
So you can
do all those operations in the Maps Data API.
Um, Maps Data
API works through the concept of feeds. These
feeds
basically manipulate three different entities,
in the Maps
Data API. We have feeds for maps, um, which
counts for a
collection of data. Now, I don't want to confuse
you and
say that we have a feed that allows you to
create what is
known as the Google Maps map with the tiles
and the paint
and all that. A map here would be a collection
of
geographic data. You might have crime statistics,
you know,
from Chicago where I was born. It seems to
be a hot topic
all the time to have crime statistics being
indexed in -- in
Data. Um, but it's the collection of that
data that you put
together, um, which counts as a map. Um, we
also have a
feed, ah, feed for features, which is an individual
feature
on that map. Um, so you can ma -- manipulate
not only the
map with -- as a collection feature, but you
can manipulate
individual features of putting the data that
you attach to
these features. And, finally, we allow you
to manipulate
access control lists, um, and that will allow
you to do your
private share and public model. Um, and we
launched the
Maps Data API at I/O last year, um, but it
was purely an
HTTP service at the time. We didn't have a
lot of features.
We have updated it, so I want to -- to give
you an
opportunity to look at those new features.
And one of the
most important is spatial search. Um, and
we also allow
attribute search. Ah, spatial search will
allow you to
search for a bunch of features within a given
radius or a
bounding box; let's say if you put it in a
map. Um, an
attribute search will allow you to search
for your own
particular data, um, within that -- that
-- that area. So
here's an example that I was talking about
with basic feed.
Now, you might think that's URL; I'm going
to get some, you
know, Web page. But that's not actually how
it works. Um,
a POST to that feed, which is the top one,
actually is
called --this is called the Default Feed;
this is a special
feed. This is a feed that basically is just
yours. Um,
and, ah, what that means is if -- if I send
a feed -- ah, a
POST your request to this, it's going to create
a map. Um,
so the initial map can be provided as XML
or Comma-Separated
Values or KML. KML turns out to be the best
to manipulate
within the Maps Data API. Um, and -- and once
you can
actually create a map here, if you send a
POST to this,
you'll get a map, um, with some URL parameters.
And you can
actually look at it in My Maps. Um, the second
kind is the
basic Feature feeds. So that's actually to
manipulate
little features. Um, as you see there, instead
of Maps
Feeds Maps, I'm going to Maps Feeds Features.
Um, so it's a
very similar URL that you would send. A POST
to this one
would act to create a map, ah -- I mean, I'm
sorry; it would
act to create a feature in the map. Um, you
see here that
it's specified. You have to specify your User
ID and your
Map ID; that means it's a per user and it's
per map. Um,
you can't have features across multiple maps,
ah, but you
can have a -- a large number of features within
any given
map. Um, and the features are exposed is KML.
So we now
support points, linestrings, and, ah, polygons.
Ah, we also
support authentication options, which is we
have, ah,
AuthSub and OAuth support. Um, and we provide
authorization
via Access Control Lists. So this is also
a -- a feed. Um,
so you can send a feed for your default feed,
which is
everyone in the world, or you can send a feed
for yourself.
Um, now importantly, the default feed, ah,
has a default of
READ, meaning that if you -- if you, ah, create
a map under
my, ah, ah, My Maps Data API, it's not necessarily
public.
It's -- it's called, ah, ah, unlisted, which
means if
someone has that ID, they can actually look
at the data. So
this allows you to create a map, create a
bunch of data, and
then share it with someone else without it
necessarily being
public. Um, but you can also change that to
be a completely
private, ah, application. So you can change
the de --
default to be to -- to -- to nothing. Um,
and, in that
case, no one is going to be able to get at
your data. Um,
and, of course, also write for yourself. Now,
if you looked
at it, you're, like, I've got to send these
URLs and
manipulate this stuff and read this stuff
back. Um, no I
didn't like doing that either. So, I mean,
URLs are a pain.
So what we've done in the Maps Data API is
we've provided
clients with libraries. Ah, when we initially
-- initially
launched, we only had, ah, Java. Ah, we only
had Python.
We went to Java in June. Um, and in December
we went to the
Javascript client library. Um, now many of
you are going to
be creating applications on your own servers.
So, in that
case, you're actually going to want to use
Java or Python
probably. Um, but I'm going to be using Javascript
today
because I can do it completely within the
browser. [ pause ]
So here's an example. The first thing you
have to do when
you use the Maps Data API is load it. Um,
and if, ah,
you're familiar with V3, you're probably familiar
with, ah,
this paradigm of loading the application.
So, you're
loading Javascript here, um, using the script
tag. Um, and
I'm loading two packages. And this is nice
and convenient
because this actually loads everything asynchronously.
So
I'm going to load the GData package Maps,
which is the Maps
Data API, and I'm also going to load Maps
API V3. Um, you
see this Google set onload callback. What
that basically
means is that when both of those packages
are ready, ah,
call that initialized function. Um, and then,
ah, here's a
simple pattern for using AuthSub to redirect
you to Google
login. Now, importantly, this is an application
that's
existing on the Internet. Someone opens it
up. If you want
to -- if you want to be able to use it yourself
to enter
data, you're going to need to provide some
sort of
authorization in that application. So this
is a good
pattern here. It basically checks whether
you're logged in;
it checks the login status. And if you're
not, it's going
to basically call these Google accounts. Um,
sorry, it's
going to call Google accounts user login.
That's going to
do the -- the three-legged dance with all
eyes. It's going
to bring you to a page where you log in and
identify
yourself, and then it's going to ask you whether
you
actually want to allow this application to
do that to your
data. And then, finally, there's a little
trick. You've
got to have an image on your page some place.
Most people
do anyway, but it's just important. This actually
holds the
authorization cookie. Um, so this may trip
you up. So just
make sure that you -- you put that. Um, I'm
going to post
all these slides on KodakCo.com when this
is done, so don't
worry about taking copious notes. Um, here's
a simple
example. Um, I talked about Creating Map.
That's the
default feed. So you see here this is Javascript.
This
isn't Python or Ja -- or, ah, or Java. Um,
so this is done
through callback functions. And we have a
Map feed URL,
which is the default feed. And, basically,
I call the
Google Map service, and I pass it that Map
feed. And I --
and I also pass it a callback function. So
that's -- what
that's going to do is that's actually going
to assemble all
these parameters. Um, I'm going to set the
title; I'm going
to set the summary. And then I'm going to
call Insert
Entry. Insert Entry is actually doing the
HTTP post there.
So that will do the whole operation. Once
that's done,
it'll return. Um, and I will get My Map, and
it'll return
in IE. Um, so that's -- that's creating a
map. You only
need to do that once. You don't need to put
that in your
application. You can just run that once, and
now you'll
have a map. You'll have, ah, a Map ID, which
consists of
your Map ID and your User ID, and that will
allow you
uniquely to get the map. So let's create an
application
with this. And I wanted to give you kind of
an application
design specification. This is a thing that
I created. Um,
I like coffee. I drink a lot of coffee. I
think I drank
six cups today. Um, and I had about three
hours of sleep.
So, in that case, you know, I want to have
a coffee rating
application. And so I can go around and have
-- have a cup
of coffee, basically click and say, hey, you
know, I like
this coffee. What kind of coffee did I have?
What's the
name of the place? That kind of thing, so
I can look at it
later. Um, I want to use the Maps Data API
V3. Um, and I
also want to use geolocation so I can find
out where I am.
These are a lot of the things that have been
talked about
today. Um, and I want to have the data populated
into the
Maps Data API. And, finally, I want to be
able to implement
search. I mean, putting data in is -- is great,
but you
also want to be able to retrieve that data
later on.
Generally, that's a good thing to do. So,
I'm going to show
this application first so you can get an good
idea. So this
is the application here. And I'll just refresh
it to make
sure you know I'm not cheating. Oh, wow. Now
I'll go to
Alameda. It didn't do that before. So I can
go to San
Francisco. [ click] [ pause ] Geocode that.
Um, and what
I want to do here is I want to basically click
and add Add a
Coffee Joint. So, if I go down to -- [ pause
] Let's just
put random coffee joint here. I click on it;
it says you
must log in entry data. So I put that little
login button
over there, and this will do that little three-legged
dance.
So, I've actually logged into my account previously.
And
what -- you've probably seen this if you're
familiar with
the Google Data. I basically have to grant
access to this
application. So I click on Grant Access. Everything
will
refresh, and it will bring me back to Alameda
for some
reason, which didn't do it today. [ pause
] [ click ]
[ pause ] Um, and I'll just give you an example.
So I
click. I say, you know, hmm, this is going
to be okay
coffee. And I have options for the type of
coffee that I
want. Um, you might not be familiar with this
last one.
It's a big popular coffee in Australia where
I'm based. I
have not actually figured out the difference
between it and
a flat white, I mean, between it and a latte.
Um, maybe you
know the difference. They both taste the same
to me. Um,
so it will allow you to select the coffee.
It will allow
you to give it the rating. And then it will
add the coffee.
Now, I put a temporary marker on there, but
it's actually
also doing that insert feature, and it's sending
that to the
Maps Data API. And if I go to my My Maps,
I'll have my
little coffee shops around the world. And
here you can see
an example -- [ pause ] -- if I can get this
bigger, of all
these little coffee joints around the world.
So you can get
an example of this is how it would be exposed
in My Maps.
[ pause ] All right, you have an idea of what
we want to
build. So I'll walk through that building.
So the first
thing you need to do is set up your map. Now,
if you've
used V3 before, all -- a lot of this will
be very familiar.
Um, there are a little bit of dif -- some
few differences
here. You see that I've put in a bunch of
global variables.
The reason I did that was because we're going
to be filling
this up in with callback functions. So these
things are not
-- so the Javascript symbols are not going
to be there until
that initialized function comes back. So,
instead, I put
these as global variables. I don't actually
give them -- I
don't actually construct anything. Um, and
I put my map ID
there just as a convenience so I can use it
again and again.
So there's that function initialized. That's
going to get
called when everything is ready. Um, I'm going
to create an
info window. I'm going to create a geocoder
-- with the,
ah, geocoder. And I'm going to create my map.
And,
basically, what I'm going to then do is called
the Geolocate
Function. Um, and then I'm going to add an
event -- ah, add
an event listener for that map on clicks that
will call
something called Open Coffee Dialogue. So
that's a pretty
simple initialization. So, the Geolocate Function,
which
somehow put me in Alameda, um, probably because
there's some
weird, ah, VLAN here. Um, I use the W3C geolocation
here
because it's -- it's the -- the best standard.
You can also
use Google Gears. Um, there's Latitude API,
people are
talking about too. So there are a variety
of different
options that you can use for your geolocation.
But,
basically, all we're doing is checking whether
geolocation
exists. And if it does, we're getting the
current position.
And then we're -- we're creating -- we're
creating initial
location with that latitude and longitude
and centering the
map in that location. Um, and if we don't
have any
geolocation, as you saw I put there a little,
ah, Take,
which would say it would take me to Moscone.
It's always a
good idea to have a default. So that click
event -- that
click event is, ah, is what's -- what's called
an Event
Handler. So I click that event, and I'll
-- what I want to
do is open that coffee dialogue box, which
you saw. So the
first thing that I'm going to do is I'm going
to populate
the location where I clicked. So I get that
from -- from
the event, event not that long. And I create
this little
HTML form. You see this actually is a form,
um, with a
table, types of coffee, um, and the ratings.
Don't really
need to go into specifics. Um, at the end,
I actually hide
the Latin Longus as -- as form values. And
then I have this
onclick save data. Um, and finally when that's
done, I
actually just basically set the content of
some HTML
supposition and open it. Um, and what --
what that -- what
that basically means is that now I've --
I've instantiated
that info window with that -- with that form.
Um, and then,
finally, when I save the data, all I simply
do is take out
those form values and stuff them in, and then
pass it off to
another function. So it's pretty simple. So
the -- the
whole meat there is that I have a map. I want
to add
features. So how do you add features? Well,
of course,
Maps Data API can support, you know, tens
of thousands of
features. Um, so you don't want to be loading
everything in
all at once. Um, instead, what you're going
to do is load
in a map and then load in individual features
that -- that
you pick. So the way you would actually access
the Feature
Feed is to get the Map feed for your map.
Get that
MapEntry, um, and then to get the MapEntry's
Feature Feed,
and then populate a FeatureEntry and insert
that in. So
it's a two-step process by design. So in this,
ah, Add
Coffee, which is being passed as variables,
what I do is I
-- I set up my map feed, which is Map URL,
which is to that
Map ID. So that's just me. Oh, excuse me there.
Um, and
then I will get the MapEntry with that, create
what --
create, ah, Get My Coffee Map, and then construct
a -- pull
out the Feature Feed URL. Now, what that means
is -- is
that what I'm taking, I'm taking that Map
feed, and I'm
getting the URL. Now, if I send a POST to
that Map feed,
you know, it's that specific Map feed. I'm
going to end up
creating a feature. So then I -- I pass all
this other
stuff off to another function. I'm doing a
little bit of
pass -- passing around here, but it's a lot
clearer that
way. So this is the meat of adding the feature,
and it's
pretty simple. Basically, I just go through
each of the
things that was passed, and I create, um,
ah, a title using
text. Um, so -- So I basically create a new
feature, which
is the Google.GData.Maps, that FeatureEntry.
And I set the
title. Um, and here's the interesting part.
The
interesting part is that I can actually put
arbitrary name
value pairs as custom data. So any data that
you want to
store, you can put in there right now. And
I use that using
the custom properties, um, of -- of KML. So
I will put the
coffee; I will put the rating. And then I
will set the
actual KML content. Now, since this is, ah,
a bunch of
coffee locations, um, it's going to be point
values. I
mean, I could have put polygons or something
like that
there; that would be complex. So I'm basically
just going
to take the latitude -- the latitude and longitude,
which I
attract from the location and create a placemark
point.
And, finally, I'm going to set that KML to
the KML string.
And I'm going to set that MIME type to --
to the KML MIME
type. Once I've done all that, I'll actually
call that
InsertEntry. And what that's -- what that's
going to do is
send an HTTP POST with that information to
My Map, and it's
going to create a feature. Um, so I'll just
go over that
again just in case. So if I click here, it
populates to the
HTML form. I just type something in, and I
do this. I
created that temporarily, but it's sending
that off as an
asynchronous request. When -- when the info
window
disappears is when it's actually created and
comes -- and
comes back. [ pause ] Okay, so that's good.
I could put
coffee joints there. But, I mean, the important
thing about
the data is actually being able to use it.
So what I want
to do is implement a search. Um, now there's
various
different ways that -- that you can do a search
in the Maps
Data API. Um, you -- a search is basically
a search over
features. So it's actually a special type
of feature
feeding. Um, so basically you -- you use the
normal feature
feed, pass, slash, snippet, which basically
means that I
want to get, you know, little bits of snippets
of
information from all of the features that
are within a
certain area. Um, and you can pass two types
of -- of
feature, ah, parameters. Um, you can -- you
can search on
attributes, which are those arbitrary name
value pairs that
I mentioned before like my -- my -- the coffee
type and the,
um, and the -- and the, ah, rating that I
gave. Those are
pass brackets, um, using the map query parameter,
the mq
parameter. Um, the example there is mq is
rating 5, for
example. Um, I've never had coffee that good.
No, wait a
minute, New York I did. Um, and then I do
spatial searches
by either a radius or a bounding box. Um,
the bounding box
is -- is a pretty convenient one for your
viewport. You --
you just basically want to take your Maps
viewport and say
like, you know, show me what's -- I'm currently
looking at.
Um, but I'll do a radius search. And, ah,
basically a
radius -- radius requires a lat and long center
and it --
and it requires a radius that's expressed
in meters. And
they have an optional sort by parameter, which
returns the
results in a specified order. And so we're
going to sort by
distance. So, basically, we're going to return
the first
results. Um, I don't actually use that because
I just
populate the stuff on the map. But you could,
for example,
use that to -- to give someone a preferred
location, like
the closest store that are there. So here's
an example of
doing the search. So I'm going to create a
button on my
map, and it's basically going to be search.
And it's going
to give it a radius of five miles. Um, so
you see that I
basically take the feature feed and just add
the slash,
snippet, um, signal, flag. I'm going to --
I'm going to
basically assume that I'm searching over the
center of the
map. So I just basically look at the center
of the map and
give that the address. Um, now, what I do
here is I
actually extract the lat and the long from
that address, um,
and then I will, ah, track the rating --
ah, rating and the
radius, and I multiply by, ah, 1609, which
is the number of
meters in a mile, if you live in a place outside
the United
States. Um, and, if I create attribute features,
basically
I'll just create an array. So they'll come
in brackets and
give it that string. And I can do that for
multiple, ah,
ratings. Um, and then, basically, there I
construct that
full URL. And then we'll send that off to
the Feature Feed.
Now, what I'm going to get back is an array
of features.
I'm not going to get just one feature. So
I -- I create an
array. Um, and then I will call another function,
Show
Results, passing it that array. [ pause ]
So I've gotten
back a bunch of features as an array. Um,
so I'll call Show
Results with those results. Um, what I'm going
to do first
is create a, ah, lat-long bounds object. The
reason I'll do
that is, basically, I'm going to try to center
the map on
all of the places that I've searched. Ah,
and I'm going to
expand the bounds with each, ah, ah, feature
that I return.
I'm also going to clear the markers, which
is just a little
trick. So I'm going to clear any previously
existing
markers. And then I'm going to iterate over
those features.
And for each feature I'm going to pull up
the title. I'm
going to pull -- I'm going to get the custom
properties and
pull up the coffee type and the rating. And
then I'm going
to get the -- going to get the KML, which,
in this case,
is -- is, ah, done with bit content bit text.
Um, and I'm
actually going to parse over the KML here,
which -- which
is, ah, is a bit of a challenge in Javascript.
But bear
with me; I have some surprises for you at
the end. Um, and
then I'm going to call -- ah -- ah, I'm basically
going to
extract the coordinates. Now note here that
I actually have
to extract and construct the lat-long with
reverse
coordinates, and that's because KML passes
longs --
longitudes kind of latitudes, and the Maps
API does the
reverse. Um, and then I'm going to create,
ah, a marker at
that coordinate with the title, um, on My
Map. And then I'm
going to attach content to each of those markers
in an info
window. And I'm go to extend the bounds, and
then I'm going
to push that marker on to a temporary array.
Now that array
-- That array there is just for convenience.
That's so
later on I can actually look through the array
and clear it
out. So, if I want to add -- when I do another
search, I
don't want previously existing markers to
-- to -- to exist.
Um, and then, finally, I'll fit the map to
the bounds of
those features. And -- this is the example
of attaching the
content, the HTML content. So I'm going to
add a listener
for -- for the click event on that marker.
Remember, this a
-- this is a listener on the mark -- on the
marker not the
map. And I'm going to set the content to that
title and the
coffee type and the rating. And I'm going
to position the
info window where the marker is, and I'm going
to open it on
the map. And there's an example of a rating
over the clear
mark -- the clear marker is where I want to
do that. So
I'll just show that again so you can get a
good idea how it
works. So I've done here -- What I'm going
to do is, ah --
I've actually lived out here for six years,
and I used to go
to Berkeley. So I will jump over to Berkeley,
and I will
search for five miles over Berkeley. You see,
that I
basically -- I retrieved four features. I
autocentered the
map. And if I go and I click on each individual
feature, I
have my little fuu coffee shop. Um, Coco is
an actual real
coffee shop. And my favorite would be Caffe
Strada. So you
have an idea here that I'm basically -- Um,
if you've worked
with KML before, you realize that it -- it
doesn't have data
-- send a data attached to it that that can
display it like
this. This is an example of -- of -- of the
versatility of
the Maps Data API is that I can pull out arbitrary
data and
populate it on a map. [pause ] Okay, so, I
mean, I've
shown you pretty quickly how you can get a
working
application done. It's a personal application.
It's not
necessarily a very robust application. Um,
I'd like to
introduce, ah, Steve Sullivan, who works at
IHG, to talk
about a more robust application that he's
developed using
the Maps Data API.
>> Steve Sullivan: Hello. Thank you. Um, as
you can
imagine, this is right up my alley. Um, I
work for a hotel
company. And we have four and a half thousand
hotels to
keep track of. And so keeping track of those
is -- is big
business for us. [pause ] So a little bit
about my
company. Um, as I mentioned, we have around
four and a half
thousand hotels. And, ah, our most upscale
brand is
Intercontinental. Um, right -- there's one
right next door
to here. Some of you may have spent the night
there or
going to spend the night there tonight. Ah,
we have Crowne
Plaza, Holiday Inn, Holiday Inn Express, Candlewood,
Daybridge, and Indigo. Um, so we get the advantages
of the
Cloud that you would expect, um, robustness.
We get speed,
reliability, all those things. And the heavy
lifting is
done by Google. So my company doesn't have
to worry about
setting up a database, opening up ports and
the firewall,
providing Web services for our applications
to access it.
Essentially, what we've done is we've gathered
the data
about our hotels, longitude, latitude, do
they have a pool,
do they have free breakfast, do they have
free Internet,
those sorts of information that you might
want to search on.
And we've pushed all that information out
to the Cloud,
using what -- what Tom showed us a little
bit earlier. We
push all that data out there. Then we can
write
applications that search on that and display
to our
customers on different applications like our
Android App
that will be launched in a couple of weeks,
our iPhone App,
which is on the market now doing really well,
and also on
our Web sites. Um, so there's a couple of
screen shots on
coming up, ah. But first I just wanted to
show here's an
example query that you can see, which [pause
] -- is very
simple. What -- Part of the beauty here, one
of the reasons
I really like this is that the -- the query
can be created
and passed a longitude-latitude radius at
a distance. We
get back an XML. We can parse this XML and
display it on a
map. So if anybody goes to HolidayInn.com
or any of our
other seven brands, you'll see this technology
being used
today. Or if you have an iPhone App, and you
search find
near -- find hotels near my current location,
it's using
this technology today. [ pause ] Here's a
couple of screen
shots of the iPhone App, of Android App and
the iPhone App.
[ pause ] So, when we were developing our
iPhone App, we
ran into a situation where we realized the
existing Web
services that we were using that were built
for companies
like Travelocity and Expedia, they didn't
have all the
information we needed. So the traditional
route would have
been let's kick off a project and have our
B2B team add
those new pieces of information that we need.
Look,
somebody had an idea and said, you know, why
don't we use
Google Maps Data API? And that was our first
use of this
technology. We had -- we had resolution to
our problem
within 24 hours. One of the developers stayed
late,
crunched some code, gathered the data --
gathered our
information up from our database, pushed it
to the Google
Data API. Our data is on that infrastructure.
The next day
we were searching on it and displaying on
this map. So
that's a great example of a traditional map
that -- which
may have taken a long time, and we'd had to
have made time
for an existing team to put that into their
schedule. And
we were able to do it overnight and have fast,
reliable
service that you see. [ pause ] So, um, that's
it. Ah,
just one closing thought on this is it's really
simple. And
so that's one of the main features that I
really like about
it. It's you push your data. You query against
it using
REST queries or the Java API, which we're
using. And your
results are, ah, back in a flash. And it's
reliable. Um,
we plan on continuing this. You're going to
see more and
more uses of this. We have all kinds of types
of
information we'd like to eventually push out.
But, for now,
ah, we're getting a lot of value out of it,
and we're going
to continue using it.
>> Tom Manshreck: Thanks, Steve.
>> Steve Sullivan: Uh-huh. Sure.
>> Tom Manshreck: Um, as I understand it,
you also used the
driving directions, Web services that we launched
today.
>> Steve Sullivan: That's correct.
>> Tom Manshreck: Yeah. So -- so the point
is that I --
that I showed you the Maps Data matched up,
um, with the --
with a V3 App. You can also use any of the
Maps API family
of services or other APIs and pull those things
together.
Um, so once you do those, you can have geocoding,
um, you
know, driving directions, elevation data we
launched -- we
launched a couple of months ago, um, and the
Place API,
which is coming out, ah, in June, which will
be especially
important for June location. So, I'm kind
of wrapping up
here, but I also wanted to give you a little
teaser. Um,
we, of course, like to have all of the stuff
to you right
now, but we do have them coming soon. Um,
you probably saw
when I was doing that little Javascript that
I was parsing
to KML. Now, parsing to KML within Javascript
is not
necessarily, um, the most elegant experience.
Um, so we
will be launching soon, ah, within the --
by the end of, ah,
Q2 -- by the end of June, um, a JSON feature
upload and
download. Um, so there's no need to parse
KML. Of course,
if you have JSON being returned within a Javascript
application, it's pretty easy to parse. It's
also very easy
to parse in Python. Um, you probably don't
need to -- to
change it because you're using Java, and Java
is pretty
robust, XML parsing built in. Um -- Yeah.
Um, well --
We'll have questions at the end; I'm sorry
-- ah, because
I'm almost done. And then the, ah, what we
also want to
announce is on the Maps Data API is -- is
a, ah, a -- a
great simple API for providing spatial data.
Um, but if you
-- But if you have a ton of data that you
want to do, like,
heat maps for -- in other words, fusion tables,
we are proud
enough that we're going to be supporting fusion
tables in
the Javascript API natively. Um, and what
-- what that
basically is going to do is you're going to
be able to have
columns and perform sequel queries. So it's
somewhat
similar to what we've done in the Maps Data
API. With the
Maps Data API would be focused on attribute
searches and
spatial searches. This would be an example
of just
selecting, um, basic -- basic -- you're selecting
your raw
data and putting up a heat map, for example.
So, I will go
to hit the live blogging reminder. And, ah,
I will
encourage you, ah, to ask questions. Let me
bring that up
and refresh. Um, so you asked about JSON-C.
So I have the
lead engineer here, and he'd like to talk
for a bit.
[ pause ]
>> Um, okay. Can everybody hear me? Um, well,
JSON-C is --
is a sort of a compressed, flattened form
of JSON that's
sort of easier to adjust if you have very
structured data.
And if you look to the KML spec, it's got
lotta lotta deep
structures. So you've got like, you know,
placemark, point,
blah-blah, or polygon, LineString, style
-- anyway. So --
so JSON-C lets you, um, have a -- a bidirectional,
not
necessarily lost list translation between
XML, the dome
structure, and JSON. So you can have something
that's
fairly flat and -- and very easy to adjust
and to manipulate
in your program. Ah, and you can -- you can
always say just
up equals JSON and -- and get a JSON, exact
JSON
representation of -- of the -- the XML. Um,
but it'll be
ugly, and it'll have the name, spaces, and
blah. And -- and
we're very close to launching the JSON-C,
which is much
cleaner and easier to use.
>> [ inaudible question from the audience
]
>> Yes, yes.
>> Tom Manshreck: Yes. Yeah.
>> [ inaudible question from the audience
]
>> Oh, yes. Yes.
>> Tom Manshreck: That fits.
>> That's the whole idea.
>> [ inaudible question from the audience
]
>> Yes. Very much so.
>> Tom Manshreck: So -- so -- so you asked
what -- whether
it would still be accessible via -- via objects,
right, in
Javascript.
>> Right, right. So like -- like the coordinates.
In KML,
it's, you know, coordinates are a bunch of
space-separated,
comma-separated numbers.
>> So, basically -- [ inaudible question from
the audience ]
>> Right. Both ways.
>> [ inaudible question from the audience
]
>> Tom Manshreck: Yes.
>> [ inaudible question from the audience
]
>> Tom Manshreck: If -- if you want to use
it that way.
Yeah, you can use it as a -- as a KML.
>> Right. Right, you can -- you can -- yeah.
It's
bidirectional.
>> Tom Manshreck: Okay. Um, I want to --
I want to get to
a couple of other questions. Um, what is the
plan to offer
other Sort By options? Only distance sorting
appears
possible. For example, what if I wanted to
sort by time or
coffee rating? Um, I know that we've tossed
around some
ideas for other sorting options, but, ah
-- Bart, if you
could, again, address this. Why don't you
come up here too.
You're probably going to get most of these.
[ pause ]
>> Bart: Um, the answer for different sorting
options is
real soon now. [ laughter ]
>> Tom Manshreck: Um, that would be multi-attribute
search
and stuff like that.
>> Bart: Right. Right.
>> Tom Manshreck: Um --
>> Bart: And the merit properties and --
yeah.
>> Tom Manshreck: Yeah. And it would, of course,
be good
to sort on your arbitrary data, because that's
-- that's
what you want to do.
>> Bart: Right.
>> Tom Manshreck: Um, will Google Map Cloud
services
support open geospatial consortium standard
APIs like WMS,
WFMS, WFST, etc. in the future? I'm not actually
aware of
-- of -- of those. I mean, obviously, we use
Atom --
[ laughter ] -- which is the --
>> Bart: Right. Atom and KML and -- and --
and KML is
acquiring other standards.
>> Tom Manshreck: Yeah. I mean, K -- K --
KML is our data
format, um, ah, for the Maps Data API.
>> Bart: They're -- they're all -- Well, I
shouldn't say
they're all interchangeable. There are some
things you can
do with these others. Um, but right now we're
focusing on
-- on KML.
>> Tom Manshreck: Yeah. Now, of course, if
there's demand,
you'll let us know.
>> Bart: Right. If you look at the KML, um,
um, reference,
you'll see a few extensions to do with --
with tours and so
on. And -- and we need to have a good answer
to GPX data.
Um, the great thing about standards is having
so many to
choose from.
>> Tom Manshreck: Yes. A question from the
audience.
>> I don't see any documentation on the, ah,
developer guide
about Search for Java. Is that the -- in the
library --
>> Tom Manshreck: Search for -- for Java?
>> Sorry. Ah, yeah.
>> Tom Manshreck: Ah, I'm not aware of that,
but, ah, we
can certainly look into that.
>> Well, so, I mean, you get the -- there's
the example of,
ah, HT -- HTTP protocol provides search, right?
>> Tom Manshreck: Yes. Yeah. There are --
There are
similar -- ah, ah, functions in -- in Java.
>> Bart: It's just a URL. There's no, like,
structured
construction of a search query.
>> There is a Java library to --
>> Bart: To construct search queries?
>> Well, I'm -- just in general for, um, um,
accessing the
-- the Data API.
>> Tom Manshreck: Yeah.
>> Bart: Yeah, yeah. It's -- it's just a
-- a feed. I
mean, you can -- you can get the slash bit
feed or you can
get the slash full projection and get, like,
everything with
--
>> Right.
>> Bart: -- with all the features.
>> Tom Manshreck: Yeah. I mean, the key point
is remember
that it's a feature feed and that the query
is actually just
extra parameters on top of that feature feed.
>> Right.
>> Tom Manshreck: So you can just do -- do
those in
arbitrarily.
>> Right. [ pause ]
>> Tom Manshreck: Yes?
>> I just had a question about, ah, it looks
a lot - a
little like Bigtable. Is it being stored there
or is it
separate?
>> Bart: Is -- Is the data stored in Bigtable?
[ laughter ]
>> Yeah. Well --
>> Tom Manshreck: I don't know. [ laughter
]
>> You don't have to say it is.
>> Tom Manshreck: I -- I don't know. And if
I did, I
couldn't tell you. [ laughter ]
>> Well, that's all right. But -- I guess
my question is --
>> Bart: I could tell you, but I'd have to
kill myself.
[ laughter ]
>> What's -- What's the advantage of -- of
using the API
versus, like, Bigtable, because Bigtable you
could do all
those searches for the different attributes.
So, is there a
speed or is there some sort of performance,
ah, that you
could --
>> Bart: Searches are blindingly fast. Um
-- [ pause ]
Can we talk about layers?
>> Tom Manshreck: Um, what -- what layers?
The Fusion
Table layers?
>> Bart: No, no, no. The -- the -- the V3
layers.
>> Tom Manshreck: Yeah, we -- we have, ah,
a -- a V3 KML
layer object that you can provide a public
URL. And it will
render those KML. It renders them as an MVC
object. So
that means that if you -- it will only pull
those features
in that are in your viewport as you move around.
It will
load those -- those in dynamically. And that
is -- is very
fast, you know. So that's -- that's an option
for getting
your data very quickly.
>> Bart: Right, yeah, um.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Tom Manshreck: Okay.
>> Bart: Sorry. [ laughter ]
>> Tom Manshreck: Any other questions?
>> Um, the Fusion Tables, I was playing around
with that a
little bit. Is -- is there an overlap between
Fusion Tables
and this Maps Data API? When should I use
one? When should
I use the other?
>> Tom Manshreck: Ah, I would say, obviously,
if you're
doing a spatial search. Um, if you're also
trying to get
something up to speed very quickly, Maps Data
API is where
-- where you would go. Um, Fusion Tables was
originally
designed to -- to have large columns of data
sets, um, for
example, to -- to, you know, -- to find, ah,
you know, the
millimeters of rainfall in Brazil and do it
by -- by
location. And then you can just have a huge
column of that.
Um, it's -- it's -- it's -- Obviously, there's
some things
you can do with both. Um, Fusion Tables have
heat maps,
which Maps Data API doesn't. So, if you want
to provide
some sort of heat maps that basically shows
denser
populations, you definitely would want to
go with Fusion
Tables. If you want to do Search, you'd want
to go with the
Maps Data API.
>> So, I can leverage Fusion Tables that show
a heat map on
my Google Maps Advert V3, ah, Web page?
>> Tom Manshreck: Yes.
>> Bart: Right.
>> I don't have to get a separate utility
library or
something like that?
>> Tom Manshreck: Nope. It will be -- it will
be native.
>> Oh. Okay.
>> Bart: Basically, it's a URL with a query,
SQL query.
Moments there. Um, I don't know what Fusion
Tables has for
an API yet. They may not have a --
>> Tom Manshreck: They -- they -- they do
have a public
API.
>> Bart: Okay. Okay.
>> Tom Manshreck: Um, and because it's MVC,
I'm not -- I'm
not sure, but I would think that you could
modify the query,
for example, and it will update with, ah,
V3. It's -- It's
MVC, meaning Model-View-Controller.
>> Bart: Right.
>> Tom Manshreck: You can update the query
and it would
update the data that -- that's shown, which,
of course, is
very powerful.
>> Bart: Right.
>> All right.
>> Bart: Obviously, there's -- there's a lot
of overlap.
And, ah, right.
>> Tom Manshreck: Okay. Well, it's the end
of the day.
Thank you, ah, for attending my talk and staying
up. And
get -- ah, enjoy the party tonight. Ah, take
care.
[ applause ]